I come into this video Papua 2929 this
is Poland right yep okay six and a half
out of seven this must be one of the
best scores and I have okay let's vary a
bit I played the Zurich variation with
knight c6 quite a lot but let's do
something else I am just pretty tough
game recently ants step by step
Bulgarian I am have to really look up my
own analysis in my book and but okay I
basically know where I went wrong in
those in the sense game but still play
let's do something else for a change not
play the same stuff all over again this
is some a different line that black has
at his disposal against them the
classical with Quincy to this line is
completely different in nature compared
to the zurich variation here black is
aiming for very quick development and
yeah we see how this can unfold here i
have all my pieces out and wow really 95
we are now k 97 27 bishop f6 but it
still does not develop anything okay i'm
not thinking for too long here I'm just
opening it up
I have the better development so things
like that should be ok yeah for Roxy
five okay he's absolutely not caring
funny yeah ok so I'm better yeah the
question is how much Queen somewhere I
can take and take before this is this is
also quite good but it's not clear if
it's enough to really play for win so I
have to consider alternatives and of
course there are some some nice ones
maybe queen bee seven here and just
checking here on before or they are up
the eighth also yeah of course queen bee
7s much stronger ok here he's
threatening Queen g4 or threatening i
mean it's it's in the it's in the game
now but i can take him chicken check
them
yeah I wonder how do how to play that
look the a it is also quite promising
and I believe check go to fh check yeah
this way I still have the half castling
prevented this was my idea by not taking
yeah here I can take take before for
look-see too is this enough that sets a
real deal the real problem there's
enough to win or do I play Queen be
sexier then you can castle
Jim I can take check before for loop see
to what I don't I really doubt that this
is enough to win c4s is the alternative
just pushing this pawn check doesn't it
doesn't seem like enough but difficult
by now to do something outside yeah but
what you were your very pacifier so
let's let's see first let's see if you
can really hold it check HERE t5 check
yeah I'm done on time but but still this
is some not so easy fam there's five
ticks yeah this is interesting I can do
this but that's not leading to Bree too
much right now it's very dry no no
question check yeah I could have taken
the draw this was probably probably wise
um I cannot play for when he rly Joe I
had it I shouldn't have taken only to
then which was my um my original
intention anyway not to take I mean time
morning Jim check
Joe no I'm sitting there with one minute
and I'm a pawn down oh it's even added
that's even though that's it's even
inconvenient I was thinking I'm drawing
very easily that's not the case if he
gets this in my king you for him check
check so I shouldn't have done that gem
the transposition into this ending okay
well that has stumbled into this end
game of porn down this is just awful and
was totally unnecessary but I simply
cannot win China have no winning chances
so I had to had to avoid that check is
kind of joke that I'm sitting in the
same game now after this position that I
had brought okay check check check
check check check and just then just
push pawn say Jack don't know why he
doesn't do it check hi Kim so black
resides then check how how I should have
played this is this is just very bad
yeah 95 I Easter's it's just absolutely
not developing anything and setting up a
position where he's just balancing yeah
on the razor's edge show quite clearly
so it takes he went here so how do i do
that i played between be seven okay okay
Quincy six is the first spot where I can
clearly improve and does the idea is
that I have loved this I have to check
on c3 this is actually already leading
to a winner minus two is this yeah I
mean there's no wonder why it has no
development whatsoever this is just
terrible okay but this is also should be
enough for a big edge but probably this
was the wrong way to go it really was
check this this this this and Queenie to
any sort of holds on this is just minus
0.7 this is not enough him from through
this position that i had c4 is best
young using the pawn well I should have
done justices this is just a bad idea I
was thinking jack there might still be
something with the activity here
but it's really there's nothing nothing
going on aunty I have to have to switch
switch to a drawing mode simply and not
not play play anything fancy him it was
really a bad idea I mean you can very
easily draw if you play stuff like a h5
for example he's not really threatening
to take the porn let's say that say
something like this Shack then a
five-win check we just just trade
everything down it's very easy to draw
but I was just playing out some some
moves and here it gets actually a bit
bit tricky yeah so how do I draw yeah
probably i should let him take on a five
and not not allow that here it gets it
gets kind of tricky this is a strong
over to age five and here are here this
is this is unpleasant and that still
should draw but chess it's unpleasant i
should go here not to make this this so
easy three against two ways two rooks is
still a fairly straightforward draw can
but this is this was getting now very
nasty my king is cut off and this is
this is probably lost em the pawn is
very weak on e6 that's not looking good
yeah okay i have to kill him right in
the opening this this opening players
just check it's just awful oops sorry
about that yeah not not developing
anything and moving the same pieces all
of the time so it should be should be
heavily punished but I didn't I i played
this actually a bit played this I didn't
play it really quickly and this is not a
bad move in itself to appreciate the
difference between queen bee 719 660
probably needs need to think about for a
moment but here this is this is a bad
this decision is just bad I took a long
time and can I kind of knew that this
doesn't lead to much but I can just do
this like here I was kind of skeptical
because of my somewhat shaky King
position but there's really nothing
going on here this is also like just
that- born now yeah it's much easier to
play this especially compared to the the
double root game game that was a bad
play okay well thanks for watching